Lots of times when,
when I'd been treating
people for depression,
for example,
or anxiety,
they have existential issues.
You know what,
it's not just some psychiatric condition.
It's not just the third tapped off of
normal because their brain chemistry is
faulty.
Although,
you know,
sometimes that happens to be the case.
It's that they are overwhelmed by the
suffering and complexity of their life and
they're not sure why it's
reasonable to continue with it.
You know,
that they can feel that terrible
negative meanings of life,
but are skeptical beyond belief
about any of the positive meanings.
I had one client who was a very brilliant
artist and as long as he didn't think
he was fine,
you know,
because he'd go and create and who
is really good at being an artist,
he just,
you know,
he had that personality that was
continually creative and quite brilliant.
Although he was self denigrating and,
but as soon as he started to
think about what he was doing,
then,
you know,
the,
it's like a,
like a drill or a thought
or something like that.
He'd saw the branch off that he was
sitting on because he'd start to criticize
what he was doing.
Even the utility of it,
even though it was sort
of self evidently useful,
and then he would be,
then it would be very,
very hard for him to even
motivate himself to create.
And He,
I,
he always struck me as a good example of,
of
the consequences of having your rational
intellect divorced in some way from
your being divorced enough so that it
actually questions the utility of your
being.
And it's not a good thing.
It's not a good thing and it's,
it's really not a good thing because it
manifests itself not only an individual
psychopathology but also
in social psychopathology.
And that's his proclivity of people
to get tangled up in etiology.